don't have to look far on the algarve to
find britons abroad
but the irresistible draw of portugal's
sandy shores
has been fleeting and the quarantine
rush has now begun
we tried all day yesterday to get
another flight home and to come home
before the time we literally were
going to land at one o'clock on tuesday
afternoon so we'd miss it by nine hours
just gutted we thought we'd at least get
seven days notice
we're lucky enough we've actually had a
holiday out of it we're here a week
but all these people are coming over on
the flights it's just not fair
and to think that we can escape for a
week and
quite safely take all the precautions
take all the jobs
pay for this pay for that and get here
and i said we weren't here for 12 hours
and we're told that
we're not supposed to be here well i
don't know when we're going home how
we're getting home whether we're going
to have to isolate
and in our business that's going to be
very very difficult
as easyjet lays on extra seats ryanair
have hiked up
prices and at faro airport passengers
are scrambling
120 euros wow even for these guys
each each wow
[Music]
fiona has had to buy seven new tickets
for almost a thousand pounds
these were teachers you know they've got
to get to school they've got they've got
people's children to teach
they can't isolate they can't arsenal
these guys have got to go to school as
well
on flights to portugal empty seats imply
abandoned holidays and for every missed
flight there's a knockoff
at the casa de paella beach bar how many
of your people come here british
normal normally is 80
80 british christmas yeah so it's a big
impact
yes do you think the british government
were right to put portugal on the amber
list
what is really unfair is to announce
that
the decisions regarding traveling would
have
a scientific basis and then in the
absence of arguments
to present a very brutally told story we
have 12
cases from these variables 12 cases
and they are controlled so and this is
not a new variant
uh it's already is in the uk
this has been the only major tourist
destination on the green list and i
think people coming here had assumed it
was
a safe bet but what has annoyed people
most
is the speed that this decision came
into force and the lack of warning that
people were given
as the government balances freedoms at
home and abroad
they say they needed to act fast and the
prospect of shawls beyond britain
has come and gone ally forskey sky news
on the algarve